we have a voicemail number and that
number is
2192 david p
uh we got a voicemail from the eggman
with a prediction
for 2024. he wants to bet
people about this take a listen to what
he had to say hey dave
i like to bet on politics and i won on
this presidential election
even though i'm not getting paid by the
schmuck who owes me because he thinks
you know
trump is going to win in court anyway
i've got to bet for you or for any of
your listeners
yeah my pillow 2024.
mike lindell my pillow 2024 is going to
run in 2024 he's not going to win he's
not going to get nominated at all
but he's going to be one of the morons
in the beginning okay
anybody want to take me up on that bet
i'll bet anything
i guarantee you this guy is going to run
for political office president
shalom brother okay um i don't think
eggman is wrong i i think that so if you
don't know who eggman is talking about
there's this guy mike lindell from the
company mypillow they sell pillows via
uh television commercials he is a big
trump supporter i believe he said trump
was a gift from god or something along
those lines
he was put front and center at some of
these early coronavirus press events as
someone who was going to be making masks
and contributing to the effort in some
way shape or form okay etc etc
guy's completely out of his mind and he
recently donated a bunch of money to
kyle rittenhouse's
um bail to two million dollar bail money
as we discussed yesterday on the bonus
show
and eggman's idea is that he may
actually run for president
i i don't think that that's out of whack
it wouldn't be unlike
um a pizza man herman cain who has since
departed
this earth due to coronavirus it
wouldn't be like some of these other
kind of edge case uh type candidates
who um are trying to get some publicity
i mean listen that's kind of how it
started with trump we don't we don't
really believe
trump thought he was going to win or was
even interested in winning early quite
quite frankly
um but i think eggman may be on to
something i would be completely
unsurprised if mike lindell
does run for president i agree with
eggman i don't think he would win
uh curious to hear from you if anybody's
interested in betting with eggman
i guess get in touch with him uh on the
bonus show today
there is this viral video that has been
going around of a trumpist
a a vile trumpist deliberately sort of
like
powerfully exhaling on people
outside a trump golf club and he has now
been charged with
simple assault for that i guess the idea
of course was to scare someone that he
may be trying to give him the virus
we are going to talk about the reaction
from the oil
industry to joe biden this issue of oil
was a big issue during the campaign and
a big topic for donald trump during his
rallies
and we are also going to talk about the
surge
in cannabis related stocks in the market
as a result of joe biden winning and
we'll talk about what we might actually
see in terms of legalization
decriminalization during
a a biden administration very
very um there are
dramatically different views as to what
joe biden is expected to do if anything
on decriminalization and legalization
and we'll be discussing that on today's
bonus show
two ways to get instant access to the
bonus show number one
very simple the preferred way get a
membership at joinpackman.com takes
under a minute
very very strong way to get access to
the bonus show
other alternative become a patron at
patreon.com david pakman
show we'll speak to you then